i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
where to even start today uh the last 24
hours have been
almost surreal
here in the united states let's start
with what exactly would i do about guns
you know one of the things that has come
up in the last 24 to 48 hours uh after
we've had not only the buffalo shooting
but also now the uvalde texas school
shooting has been when people say we've
got to do something about the guns there
will be those on the right who say what
exactly do you want to do steve kerr the
coach of the nba's golden state warriors
went on this impassioned rant and many
like ben shapiro and others said i don't
hear any specifics suggestions there so
let me give you my specific things that
i would try with a couple of caveats as
we get into this whatever anyone
proposes whatever i propose whatever is
ever proposed
you will always have people saying
that won't solve the whole problem this
one idea won't solve the whole problem
of mass shootings or even the sub
problem of mass shooting specifically in
schools and they're correct
this is such a widespread issue
that no one thing will solve or prevent
every mass shooting but that's a reason
to do many things rather than to do none
so that's number one you know no one
treatment cures all cancer
blood pressure medication alone doesn't
prevent
all strokes and heart attacks but you
say well let's do blood pressure
medication uh exercise diet meditation
whatever seat belts don't stop every car
death but we say seat belts are one tool
safe for cars or another crash testing
is another road design is another driver
education okay
i also saw a post bemoaning that the
left has all the same ideas as to what
to do as we had 10 years ago we've tried
none of them of course we're going to
have many of the same ideas we've not
tried any of these things
and many of us believe that they would
work so uh let's
get into
the list of things that i would do
uh and go through them one by one first
we've got to end the gun show loophole
the gun show loophole refers to the fact
that federal law doesn't require
unlicensed private sellers like me if i
just have some guns and i want to go to
a gun show and sell them there's no
federal law that requires a background
check for gun purchases uh that's the
gun show loophole okay you've gotta you
gotta close that number two universal
background checks when we talk about a
universal background check it would
require
um
essentially every firearms transaction
in the united states to be recorded and
to go through the national instant
criminal background check system and
that is sometimes called the private
sale exemption you've got to deal with
that universal background checks aren't
required by u.s federal law you've got
22 states and dc that require them for
at least some private sales but that's
gotta go federal number three we need a
mandatory waiting period from the time
that you go and you say uh i want the
gun
to the time when you get the gun
absolutely imperative you've got to have
a mandatory waiting period four what
about no high capacity weapons for those
under age 25 you can get your your your
you know single action uh uh firearms or
your handgun i guess at age 18
but you've got to wait until age 25 for
certain high-capacity weapons number
five mandatory gun insurance maybe even
gun insurance that's more expensive
without a parent co-signing if you're
under 25. i'll get back to that uh what
about a required community support
letter for anyone under 25 who wants a
gun meaning you've got to have i don't
know sort of like you would have two or
three references for a job
you need two or three references from
people over age 25 if you are under age
25 i'll get back to why that may be a
really important thing
number seven we probably want to ban
some weapons yes they're there we
already do it right you can't get nukes
you can't get shoulder-mounted rpgs
we might just expand that list a little
bit there are simply some weapons that
are of no real value except as mass
killing machines i'm not pretending that
i have the exact point at which you draw
the line but we probably want to look at
that number eight a periodic mental
health evaluation including when you
first obtain the firearms um all these
right wingers saying the problem is
mental health well okay let's do
something about it
require an initial and a periodic mental
health evaluation number nine an
extensive licensing process okay you
need a written and practical test for a
driver's license it should be the same
for guns also the training and licensing
period shouldn't be one weekend it
should be longer like with cars uh and
we do uh we should have a gun buyback
program okay that will make the off ramp
for lots of people
much more reasonable there should be a
gun buyback program they've worked in
many other countries now many of you
will see that list and you will say but
david sir if you're that polite
not not those things wouldn't have
stopped
this specific shooter in uvalde texas
well some of the things i listed would
have had no impact like the gun show
loophole would have had no impact uh in
this particular case but others would
okay 18 year old shooter uh if you
got got the guns legally right because
these were guns that he was allowed to
get if you limit high capacity weapons
to age 25
then this shooter might have had a
handgun and almost certainly fewer
people die if this particular shooter
had only a handgun having to have a
certificate of gun insurance
might have dissuaded the guy from going
and getting those guns because it would
have been an additional cost
community support letters everybody has
been posting to social media
that we knew about we knew about this
guy there were adults in the area who
knew this guy was unstable well if
that's true it might have been more
difficult for this shooter to obtain two
or three community support letters from
adults saying i think it's fine for this
individual to have a firearm it would
have been an obstacle a mental health
evaluation could have been an obstacle
okay so some of these things wouldn't
have affected this particular shooting
some of these would the intangible of
course is culture
how do you deal with american gun
culture
uh for many americans that are insular
and don't know what the rest of the
world is like they may not realize how
bizarre it is that we have this
fetishizing of guns celebration of gun
culture condemnation of intelligence and
uh i was it asimov i think it might have
been isaac asimov who said something
along the lines of
um and this was in the 80s i hope i'm
quoting this roughly correctly something
along the lines of uh
my ignorance is seen as a legitimate
counterpoint to your intelligence
it's something like that
uh we have a real cultural problem in
the united states as well and i admit
none of my ideas would impact that okay
so there are some ideas and hey guys
nothing else is working so we might as
well try these things let me know your
thoughts there are growing questions and
we still don't know the full scope of
this about what the hell were police
doing during the 40 to 60 minute period
that the 18 year old duvalde texas
shooter was in the school now this is
not about
criticizing police it's about thinking
critically
about the supposed solutions that
republicans say would be solutions we
need to think about whether that makes
any sense given what we are now learning
took place in uvalde texas we are now
learning
that while the gunman was inside the
school for 40 to 60 minutes after being
confronted by an armed officer
uh police were just outside stopping
parents desperate from going in to try
to stop the shooter now you could say
well those parents could have gotten
themselves skilled true but what why
were why weren't the police in the
school why weren't the police actually
uh uh doing something during those 40 to
60 minutes that would have had an impact
we now have footage
okay there is now footage of armed
police
outside the school during the shooting
pinning a man believed to be a parent to
the ground okay take a look at this
[Applause]
and you might so you see here police
have a guy pinned to the ground that's
not the shooter that's believed to be a
parent or some kind of school employee
desperate to go in and do something
because the police weren't
[Applause]
okay i think you get the idea
department of public safety director
steve mccraw told reporters that 40 to
60 minutes elapsed from when the gunman
opened fired until when the tactical
team got in and shot the gunman
according to the two officials
the shooter went into a classroom and
locked the door
police on scene left him in there when
border patrol showed up they couldn't
break down the door and after 40 to 60
minutes a member of the school staff
unlocked the classroom door with a key
so we're still getting the details here
this is increasingly being looked at
what on earth happened but my point is
less about i mean listen we need to
investigate why police did what they did
there there are anecdotal reports and
it's still early
but there are anecdotal reports that the
reason it was border patrol ultimately
was that the police on scene were were
refusing to go in now that's just it's
an assertion that's been made and we
want to be really careful and make sure
we know what actually happened but the
question we need to grapple with here is
if this is what trained police did
how on earth do we think that armed
civilians in the schools are the
solution armed teachers
or armed janitors or armed lunch ladies
it doesn't make any sense and so we need
to figure out the specifics of what
happened here for sure
but there are a lot of other questions
that remain unanswered bigger picture
about what should be done a beto
o'rourke confronted the texas republican
governor and lieutenant governor
yesterday at a press conference about
the uvalde texas shooting and beto was
marched out by police officers okay
uh there are some who are saying this
was a despicable uh a grandstanding
attempt i completely disagree a betto is
actually showing passion and concern for
what's going on beto is not blaming
doors like republicans and clies
increasingly are let's look at the
confrontation you will hear that as uh
governor of texas greg abbott who said
mental illness is the only problem here
greg abbott tries to turn it over to dan
patrick
the lieutenant governor and then beto
interrupts and then they start insulting
beto and telling him he's
embarrassing or whatever and then beto
is ultimately removed by police this
time i will
pass the mic to lieutenant governor dan
patrick
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
so if you're listening beto has now been
approached by police
right now and you are doing nothing no
he needs to get his ass out of here this
isn't the place to talk to him this is
totally predictable
sure you're all alive
they do not like being confronted do
they and you see ted cruz like a statue
on the stage
i'm sure you are online please leave
this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
he's called the sick son of a [ __ ] for
making this a political issue when is
the right time to to talk about the
politics of what's going on because it's
a political issue
for a republican governor and a
republican lieutenant governor
who are willing to consider any solution
to the gun violence problem as long as
it doesn't involve dealing with the guns
that's politics and this idea of oh
you're injecting politics give me a
break
[Applause]
and there is beto
marched out of there by police oh beto
was rude let's denounce him for his tone
he didn't wait his turn to speak he
didn't wait enough days before it's okay
to talk about politics beto is saying
what anyone with common sense has been
thinking and saying for a really long
time
and they are doing politics by packing
the stage with republicans they're doing
politics by excluding dealing with gun
safety as a solution they'll blame doors
uh rap music i'm gonna play a clip later
of them blaming rap music and yet uh
shame on beto and uh betto after getting
kicked out he kept going outside this is
another viral video more than two
million views 50th in the nation in
mental healthcare access 50th there are
only 50 states in the nation we are dead
last the number one provider of mental
health care services under greg abbott
in the state of texas is the county jail
system in the state of texas the largest
inpatient mental health care facility in
the state of texas is the harris county
jail all right so you get the picture
and listen beto beto did nothing wrong
when when nobody else is willing to do
anything that connects to the actual
issue
at least he's out there trying to get
some attention
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman we'll take a quick
break and be right back
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the u.s
i've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why i now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and i can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name or it takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below
well the national rifle association has
put out a statement responding to the
shooting in uvalde texas you may also
recall that the national rifle
association is having its annual
convention in texas starting tomorrow
friday donald trump is scheduled to
speak there republican texas governor
greg abbott is scheduled to speak there
ted cruz is scheduled to speak there so
the nra puts out this response and i
don't know whether to call it disgusting
i don't know whether to call it depraved
or dystopian but it's definitely really
bad take a look at this the nra
statement on the shooting is quote our
deepest sympathies are with the families
and victims involved in this horrific
and evil crime
on behalf of our members we salute the
courage of school officials first
responders and others who offered their
support and services
okay although there's increased
questions as to whether how and why the
police confronted the shooter outside
the school
and then the shooter went in and spent
40 to 60 minutes shooting up a classroom
until police ultimately went in and
stopped him kind of a weird thing the
nra continues to say although an
investigation is underway and facts are
still emerging we recognize this was the
act of a lone deranged criminal
a lone deranged criminal
with really easy access to guns
with no requirement for gun insurance
with no limitations on high-capacity
firearms despite being only 18 years old
thanks to in part the lobbying actions
of the nra
uh and by the way the whole uh you know
as they say here a lone deranged
criminal gets to the mental illness
component
also
in a country that says half of the
country says mental illness is the
problem but they won't fund mental
health treatment
uh as we gather in houston the statement
goes on to say
we will reflect on these events
pray for the victims
recognize our patriotic members
in the midst of this your members or the
patriots what and pledge to redouble our
commitment to making our schools secure
so
on the prayer
i'm a little sick of the after the fact
prayer once people are dead
if the prayer worked why wouldn't it
prevent the shootings if you pray the
right way pray to prevent the shootings
and yet they keep happening and the most
insidious thing is we're going to
redouble our efforts to make schools
secure
the nra exists to sell guns
okay
when they say redouble our efforts to
make schools secure
they're talking about arming teachers
and arming everyone to sell more guns
for their clients their clients are the
gun manufacturers at the end of the day
a disgusting statement from the nra
obviously the convention should be
canceled but in fact donald trump is
doubling down on speaking there and
we'll get to that a little bit later
let's talk about
solutions so-called
to the gun violence problem i'm going to
play a clip for you here
of the last roughly 24 hours of fox news
and the roughly 50 solutions that they
have proposed to the issue of gun
violence it might not come as a surprise
that none of the solutions relate to gun
safety
okay
uh
let's just take a listen and see if you
can find the trend here i'll give you a
hint it's none of these things have to
do with guns unless you mean giving more
people guns i advocate always for an
armed security guard armed school safety
officer armed
deputy arming teachers potentially arm
and prepare and train teachers and other
administrators armed school staffers
bring in policemen training
the students themselves retired military
retired law enforcement we can offer
them tax breaks if you give law
enforcement the opportunity to impose
martial law we can guarantee safety and
security securing that perimeter kind of
providing kind of a ring of steel you
have the fences you have the main
administration building and then you
have wide gaps on either side the
fencing's not very high where the doors
locked bulletproof glass all of these
shootings have happened at the same time
that we see religion
and christian values and that's another
one it's got the problem isn't guns the
problem is lack of god judeo-christian
values declining anybody who decides
that they want to do something like this
should immediately know
that attacking a school is a death
sentence for them kids are afraid of
being the school snitch we have to stop
letting these schools be gun-free zones
people need to put their phones down and
get to know the person next to them we
have spent billions of dollars on covet
related measures for our schools let's
take some of that money and divert it
over to hardening these soft targets a
lot of these private schools they take
security way more serious parents take
your children to church this anti-police
narrative is forcing people not to call
police a series of interlocking doors at
the school entrance that are triggered
by the way how absurd people are not
calling the police the police were on
the scene 40 to 60 minutes while the
shooter was rampaging in the classroom a
tripwire and it traps the shooter like a
rat god is the answer to that there's a
moral rot going on that we all need to
dig in and try to address i vote for
decreasing social media exposure we need
to start focusing on mental health tell
us why you think it's important to pray
in a moment like this it calls for faith
and prayer why is it that schools are
protected in the same way that airports
there are some people who don't want a
police officers in schools with guns
because other people are triggered
assault rifle triggering is the people
being triggered is the problem it's body
armor a notification system to let
everybody in the school know what's
happening
to a point of entry i don't like talking
about this stuff as it happens because i
don't think it contributes anything
positive parents should be held
accountable for raising their children
properly holistic blankets we just don't
have the resources to get law
enforcement there quickly how about an
executive order for these mental health
facilities we have to start rebuilding
this country and returning to god i arm
myself everywhere i legally can it's up
to you to protect yourself
wow
oh boy guys that we're we are screwed as
a country dear god um by the way you
know a couple of those suggestions
ballistic blankets and armor-plated
backpacks for kids
the very same people who for two years
have been saying oh if you make kids
wear masks in schools the psychological
effect of that is going to destroy them
now they're saying
let's send children to school with
ballistic blankets and bulletproof
backpacks to be taught by armed teachers
in a school surrounded by tripwire with
prison-like fences and airport security
come on guys
this is this is absolutely absurd
and i want to focus next on this issue
of doors now they're blaming doors
all right uh this is not a saturday
night live skit
this is not a joke
they are now blaming doors for the
shooting in uvalde texas this is truly
beyond parody
uh we're gonna look at a video here of
ted cruz
uh ted cruz is not the only one talking
about this you see here a little
screenshot
from uh texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick sorry i'm having trouble getting
it on the screen here it is
um too many entrances and exits on
campuses okay so let's look here is ted
cruz when he was uh in uvalde yesterday
came across this new idea let's not talk
about guns let's talk about doors do you
want to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street
look the killer this is a principled and
defiant ted cruz bravely coming out
against doors entered here the same way
the killer entered in santa fe through a
back door an unlocked back door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including he's furious at doors guys
he's furious at doors
not having unlocked
back doors including not having unlocked
doors to classroom having one door that
goes in and out of the school having
armed police officers at that one door
uh then he went on fox news he this
started to get some traction so then he
went on fox news and did the exact same
routine about doors school's safer and
one of the things that that everyone
agreed is don't have all of these
unlocked back doors have one door into
and out of the school and have that one
door armed police officers at that door
if that had happened if those federal
grants had gone to this school when that
psychopath arrived the armed police
officers could have taken him out
remember the armed police officers were
there and they did confront the suspect
and then he went in for 40 to 60 minutes
to rampage in the classroom think about
the absurdity of these people there's
too many doors it's not too many guns
there's just too many doors now let's
talk about doors okay
at the high school i went to
now during school hours all of the doors
are locked going in you still have the
push bar so you can get out but the only
door that's unlocked going in is the one
that leads directly into the front
office where people have to check in
fine i mean okay do that that's fine but
remember an armed officer did confront
the shooter outside of the school
and then the shooter went in
and then we're learning that he was in
there 40 to 60 minutes after the
confrontation what the hell is going on
here what how how is doors the the issue
uh secondly children never go outside
for recess
uh when you when the the other concern
from security experts about the one door
thing is
if everybody knows the one door that's
being used
then the shooter can just hang around
right at that door there are fire code
issues as well and you know when when
ted cruz says
we got a psychopath here and the doors
is what we need to do well why wouldn't
the psychopath target the kids backed up
in the line to get in the one door that
will let them through so locking doors
having a police officer at the school
bulletproof windows these are reactions
but they're not solutions okay and by
the way imagine that you do this at
schools do you do it at the grocery
store because the buffalo shooting was
at the grocery store well what if it's
the parking lot to the grocery store
well i guess you put in fencing around
the parking lot and go through tsa style
security to even get into the parking
lot for the for the super guys churches
now okay you've got to solve the issue
of people trying to do the shootings
the doors are not going to be the
solution and ted cruz was actually
confronted by a sky news journalist of
all people we're going to look at that a
little bit later after we speak to
jonathan height quick break back after
this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today jonathan height who is an
author social psychologist and professor
at nyu's stern school of business he
recently wrote an article for the
atlantic called why the past 10 years of
american life have been uniquely stupid
jonathan always great to talk to you
thanks dave it's great to be back with
you so in the in the article you um talk
about a number of different things uh
you lead with the story of babel as a
sort of metaphor for what's happened in
the united states uh since the 20s
starting in the 2010s and the sort of
fractured nature of the country you talk
about social media you talk about
political discourse you've talked about
the impact of trumpism sort of on
discourse in society for people who
maybe have not yet read the article and
will link to it and everybody should
can you give us sort of a flowchart a
directional flowchart of the the
phenomena you observe
sure yes uh thank you for that for that
that's a good setup because we think in
narrative we think in stories things
make sense what we're going through now
is so hard to understand but if we tell
the story it goes like this
in 1989 the berlin wall falls we have
this incredible period of optimism about
democracy this is also the period of the
early internet we have this incredible
period of optimism about technology for
those who remember the early internet
was this magical incredible place
um we get into the the early 2000s of
course we do have 911 we do have things
get a little darker but that decade
the early social media platforms uh the
the optimism wikipedia i mean it was
just incredible what this technology was
going to do for democracy um i'd like to
bring readers back now to the peak year
of 2011 a year that starts with the arab
spring and we think what dictator can
stand up to to people empowered by
facebook and other platforms right um
that year ends with occupy wall street
we think the people empowered so 2011 we
really is the peak year of
techno-democratic optimism
2012 barack obama's re-elected gay
marriage resolutions are passing all
around the country so it looks like this
direction to history is clearly one
direction and it would be the direction
that would be favored by by progressives
and then everything goes to hell
beginning around 2014 a lot of weird
stuff happens in 2014. my argument in
the essay is that tribalism is very old
this left right dynamic is very old but
something changed in the 2010s that made
us afraid of each other that made it
very easy for people to intimidate each
other and that leads to fragmentation
within the left fragmentation within the
right and the key metaphor
if you go back to the tower of babel
story in genesis it's very short little
story the key line is that when god is
offended by humanity's hubris he says
let us go down and confuse their
language
so that they may not understand one
another and that's what's new the break
it's not just the it's not the
cross-party hatred that's been going on
for a while we've had that before it's
this new thing of just everything
breaking up we can't understand each
other that piece reminds me you know
oftentimes people will talk about
orwell's 1984.
but what you just mentioned about the
confusion
is really more reminiscent to me of
aldous huxley's brave new world where
it's a sort of uh you could say a fire
hose of falsehood or or this inability
to sort of discern what's real or what
isn't is that an apt analogy to what
you're describing um it's you know there
are elements of both right we all read
you know from my generation we all read
those two works in ninth grade or
whenever it was yeah and that's the way
the 20th century thought about things
you know either it's going to be you
know dictators like stalin and hitler or
it's going to be some like techno
oppression
but neither of those anticipated the
decentralization revolution that is um
what what's happening now has some
echoes of you know the stasi in east
germany and people are afraid to speak
and people can rat on each other but
there's no dictator
and so just as you know i've been
learning a little bit about
cryptocurrencies and you know
decentralized finance we've talked about
defy in the same way you might speak
about detote that is there can be
decentralized totalitarianism without
any
totalitarian or any leader we can all be
afraid of each other and that has
effects that suppress discourse suppress
people dissenting on both sides
moderates in particular are afraid to
speak up because on the right you're
going to get death threats and and be
horrifically attacked on the left he'll
be called a racist or transphobe so
social media makes it very easy for the
passionate extremes to attack the
moderates and to attack leaders that i
think has messed us all up since around
2014. how did uh donald trump sort of
exploit the these circumstances
donald trump uh
the diagnosis i hear from my friends who
are clinical psychologists is
narcissistic personality disorder um he
everything's about him he is not an evil
genius he is not manic he's not like
this like brilliant mannequin behind the
scenes manipulator he is what he is he
is a narcissist uh with very little
self-control um and he just does what he
does and it just so happens
that the political world the
communications world went insane around
2014
to allow someone like him to actually be
out there tweeting
and you know we have negative
partisanship the more you attack the
other side the more people like you on
your side
so my argument is that donald trump
didn't cause the collapse of the tower
of babel he certainly made things worse
he made everything worse made the
passions worse made the norms worse i
mean i blame him for a lot but had he
never run
most of these things would still have
happened not quite as intense that they
would have still happened
um he benefited because
in the pre-babel era before we were all
fragmented people saying the things he
said like that was automatic exclusion
like everybody would have shunned him
you know but but afterwards nothing
makes sense anymore there is no
overarching narrative it's babble all
the way forward yeah one of the things
that i think resonates with me in terms
of understanding that period is
it seemed that it became much more
acceptable to publicly say a lot of the
things that before
some people understood i think this but
i probably shouldn't say it i shouldn't
say it at work i shouldn't say it on
social media it was sort of normalized
to some degree that's right well that's
right and there was such a thing as
polite society there were some norms
that were widely shared maybe not on the
far right and far left but there was a
sort of a you know a general consensus
of polite society and you could be
outside you could quickly get yourself
outside polite society part of what i'm
arguing is that
is that there's always let's let's say
how much voice does do people have at
each point on the on the spectrum and
it's always the case that people who are
angry and louder are going to have more
voice because they try harder so the
middle has less and the extremes have
more
when social media comes in and i don't
mean early social media i mean only
after we get the like button the retweet
button that's 2009 we get threaded
comments in 2013 which encourages
everyone to fight with everyone in the
comments section
it's this new hyper-viralized
environment that's what changes things
and when that happens now the extremes
get much more voice and the middle 80
percent gets much less
many of us we just keep our heads down
people are exhausted they don't want to
speak up and we can't have a
deliberative democracy when most people
don't want to even join the discussion
and when the people in the discussion
are incentivized literally incentivized
to be assets the more of an asset you
are the more you say things that are
extreme the more you will be successful
so the incentives are so antithetical to
what we need in our deliberative
democracy you you talked about the
spectrum uh there's this book waves of
rancor which i think might might not
even be in print anymore which talked
about the early days of uh talk radio uh
how it was dominated by sort of uh
conservative ownership as well as by uh
church radio low power church radio and
that this was part of why the right
started to dominate talk radio now one
of the things i also think is a factor
is that these some of these platforms
are better vessels for some right-wing
ideas so like for example if you think
about taxes the right-wing idea of taxes
are bad maybe they're theft maybe
they're slavery let's just make them as
low as possible it's super simple and
concise and it's great for talk radio
the position on the left is not let's
make taxes as high as possible it's well
we need the right level of taxation to
account for the social programs we want
you right so it's already sort of like
structurally a problem is this to some
degree also a factor
but maybe
even more so when it comes to social
media the number of characters that are
allowed on twitter and this type of
thing
absolutely um if you think about the
conditions under which people can have a
discussion when they disagree
here's a really really bad way to do it
how about
let's bring people together and have
them be perhaps anonymous
let's bring people together have no
shared past no shared future it's a
temporary interaction
let's bring them together in a place in
which you guarantee that there is no
context whatever you say will be taken
out of context because there is no
context especially twitter twitter of
course being the worst of all um
and let's do it let's have this
discussion take place in the middle of
the roman coliseum
so that the stands you're having a
discussion with someone but you're not
really talking to the person you don't
really care about the person the
audience
thousands of people all around cheering
for blood
some are on your side some are on the
other person's side um now what are the
odds that you're gonna have a good
discussion about what do you think the
proper tax rate should
what should we do about immigration like
you know you cannot have a discussion so
uh so your question started with talk
radio and that is a huge part of our
polarization that's something i didn't i
mentioned in the atlantic article i
should have said spent more time on
talk writer really does radicalize the
right in the beginning of the 70s but
especially in the 90s fox news
and all the talk radio stars
doesn't have a similar effect on the
left but i think my sense is that while
talk radio made the right radicalize in
the 90s
social media made the left radicalize in
the mid-2010s there's been a lot written
from matt iglesias originally and others
calling it the great awokening an
intensification of well you know
wokeness is the word used by the right
but it really did change the dynamics on
the left there's always been a and there
still isn't the democratic party a
healthy debate between more the far left
and the moderate level so in the party
that dynamic is still going on whereas
in the republican party there is none
all the moderates are dead or expelled
so the republican party i say in the
paper the republican party has become
the stupid party you become stupid when
you shoot your moderates if you don't
have dissent if you have orthodoxy you
become stupid you'll be wrong on most
things the republican party is the
stupid party the democrats are not but
my argument is that if you look in many
of our epistemic institutions that is
those that generate knowledge
universities media the arts journalism
these of course are dominated by
progressives that's always been the case
and it's very much the case now
when those places like the new york
times when people can't dissent within
a progressive organization then that
organization becomes structurally stupid
and so i think social media has
intensified the power of progressive
activists in a way that has often
suppressed dissent on the left and i
think that actually in the long run i
think that hurts the left yeah we talked
before the start of the interview about
how there is an asymmetry in how the
extremes on either side are sort of
impacted by the status quo i'd love to
hear you talk a little bit about that
but i also think it's important to
mention
the extreme of the left however we
define it and i think sometimes what's
called extreme maybe isn't that extreme
by global standards but let's put that
aside for a moment it doesn't seem to
have that much power in the democratic
party as evidenced by
on reddit and twitter in 2020 it looked
like bernie was just running away with
this thing and it wasn't even close in
terms of how democratic voters actually
voted in the primaries
that's right no you're right it doesn't
have that much power within the party
and that's the asymmetry
there's there's a great quote from john
stewart mill it's something like in all
of the great disputes about social
matters each side has been right in what
it affirmed though wrong and what it
denied
and when i talk to people on the left
they can i mean the number of crimes
committed by the republican party
certainly from denying barack obama's
supreme court appointment to trying to
storm the capital to overturn i mean the
crimes are it's unbelievable the crimes
the republican party has committed and
there is no comparison to what the
democrats have done so people left are
certain of that and they're right
they're absolutely right why don't those
damn republicans realize that well not
talk to conservatives there you know
some will acknowledge that yeah you know
the party you know i'm not so
comfortable with this but
and then boy do they have a list of
crimes of what the cdc did what the
media did what the universities did and
they could they've got videos and
they've got quotes and they're quotes
from people that you know so here's what
i'm saying there's this giant asymmetry
and it's as in an argument between two
spouses each side
they've got their list of violations the
other and they don't match up it's not
we're not talking about the same thing
um so that's why you know look i've
always been on the left i was always
trying to help the democrats
speak more intelligent about morality
that's why i got into political
psychology
but when i wrote the righteous mind in
2011 i was writing in 2011 i began to
get concerned like oh my god actually
our country is coming apart i mean the
partisanship is becoming outrageous this
is really dangerous and so i started
focusing more on how do we fix our
institutions get our political game
working so that we can address these
problems
and now i'm in a state of complete panic
because i think if you look at the
trends we are so far from
we're so far from even understanding not
just the other side but what our own
side is doing we are so confused we are
basically lost in babel
last thing i want to ask you about and i
know our time is not unlimited um if we
narrow down a little bit and think about
if and how social media should be
managed or regulated based on your
interpretation every idea is out there
from no regulation whatsoever just like
allow everything and let it police
itself to we need some kind of
nonpartisan government board but who
decides who's on the board and all of
the problems that come with that
what what where is your thinking on this
at this okay well so first so my
thinking is first please stop talking
about content moderation and you framed
it the way everyone does is are we going
to have more
less no i don't want to talk about that
because it's the question it's just are
we going to move it up or down a little
bit elon musk would have moved it down
we'd write less moderation democrats
no that's not where the action is so
what's the right question
but the right question is
uh
what is this what is this technology
this platform that has changed our
discourse what is the architecture what
are the dynamics of this new platform
after 2009 that has made it not
we're never going to stop people from
posting crazy nonsense but why is it
that after 2009 the crazier the nonsense
is the further it goes
what changed and how can we unchange it
and so there's two things the first
thing to attend to is who
who is on the platforms and here right
now any russian agent can create a
thousand accounts a day and run them
either personally or with bobs any jerk
any [ __ ] and there are people who are
trolls who have personality disorders
they get to harass as many people as
they want they get to make death threats
nothing happens maybe they can't get
shut down they can make 100 more
accounts
the first thing is we must have
uh user verification you can still post
with a fake name but to get an account
with posting privileges we can't just
let everyone make a thousand fake
accounts that's insane
so any large platform and eli must even
propose this at least partially but
ident authenticate users so that's one
pay attention to whether we whether you
have to at least show you're a person
and old enough like that would cut down
on a lot of it the second thing
um is the dynamics of amplification
right now the incentives are the nastier
you are the further you go let's try to
reverse that so it'd be very easy for
facebook or twitter to um quantify using
ai and and person and human coders how
aggressive is each person you get an
aggression score if all you do is say
you know screw you jerk with exclamation
points you get a five you're like you
know overall on average you're a five on
a one to five scale
and what i'd like to see is when we
start to open an account your default is
the filter set to four
so um i will see only people are four
and below and the people are five i
don't see them they don't see me i don't
want them in my public square they don't
belong in the public square
now if i want to lower my filter to
three or two i can do that if i want to
see the ass i can raise it to five
if we did that
the incentive would not would be no
longer be as much of an ass as you can
it would be you know what if you're a
complete ass you're gonna lose most of
the world they're not going to listen to
you so that's the sort of change that'll
be completely transformative whereas the
eternal argument about more or less
content moderation who decides and
where's the line that hasn't gone
anywhere in 100 years 200 years it's
never going to go anywhere
uh absolutely fascinating ideas we've
been speaking with jonathan height uh
the article in the atlantic is called
why the past 10 years of american life
have been uniquely stupid jonathan
always really appreciate your insights
thanks so much david let me just end by
saying i've put all my resources on a
single web page if you go to jonathan
height dot com slash social media i have
everything you could want to know about
the effects of social media on teen
mental health and on democracy links to
hundreds and hundreds of academic
articles so that's a sort of a one-stop
shop where i show my work
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show there are basic
fundamental questions that have to be
asked of every elected official
and they often are not being asked and a
british sky news journalist confronted
texas republican senator ted cruz
yesterday and asked him
very obvious and specific questions
about the gun violence problem in the
united states ted cruz didn't like it he
accused the guy of playing politics and
he walked away
uh sky news is no left-wing
bomb-throwing network sky news is the
british version of fox news let's take a
look at what happened and not unwelcome
there are 19 sets of parents
who who are never going to get to kiss
their child good night
again
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important by the way
this this is a this is a focus group
tested technique
if anyone ever brings up gun policy you
pejoratively say that that's politics
that's politics and politics is bad and
it's the wrong time for politics this is
just a tool it's a crutch that they use
but the reporter is not going to be
dissuaded the heart of the issue i i get
that that's where the media likes to go
and so that's the second layer of the
attack okay ted cruz is doing all the
right things from the point of view of
republican disinformation if anyone asks
about guns you call it politics if they
press you you say this is what the media
likes to do because the media is bad if
you're a republican okay but the
reporter is not going to be dissuaded
it's not it's where many of the people
we've talked to here like to go the
proposals from democrats in the media
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two ar-15s if
you want to stop
violent crime
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this well
actually
i gave a list of 10 ideas at the top of
the show
four of which would have potentially had
an impact in this particular case but
they don't want to try any of them why
does this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it you get
your political agenda no it's honestly
yeah the political agenda of right-wing
sky news the british version of fox i
mean truly a pathetic coward i'd love
you senator it's not i just want to
understand why you do not think that
guns are the problem why is this just an
american problem now another reporter
jumps in
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
mass shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why is it
that people come from by the way now he
starts pointing at at the guy's chest
with the finger all over the world to
america because it's the freest most
prosperous safest country
and it may be the free
yeah
um
when is the time for politics out of
curiosity like what i mean by that is no
matter when you try to talk about guns
they say this is not the trump the the
time for politics we need these direct
questions that was not some left-wing
bomb throwing network that was sky news
and now on friday or saturday ted cruz
will be at the nra convention saying oh
we got to say a prayer and we've got to
make sure that we keep our right to
defend ourselves good job by the sky
news reporter
and um these are the exact types of
questions they need to be asked and that
they would hopefully be forced to answer
uh they're now blaming rap music and
then of course the classic video games
as well as covet lockdowns for the
shooting in texas anything but guns
let's jump right into the first clip
ronnie jackson uh trump's former doctor
the guy who said trump six three and
weighs 239
uh he said listen they're focusing on
guns but we've got rap music and video
games to contend with our prayers and
our thoughts are with the families there
it's just it's unbelievable it's just a
unbelievable evil and i just i don't
know how someone could actually do
something like this i think you know
there's going to be all kinds of
discussions coming up unfortunately you
know in the media regarding a second
amendment and regarding uh
the the other issues
around guns in in this country but i
think we really need to ask the question
as well how could something like this
happen how could somebody do something
so evil i mean what kind of person what
kind of animal can do this and i think
you know we i i grew up in a small town
in west texas uh not too much uh not not
too much smaller than uvalde and i could
never imagine something like this
happening when i grew up but when i grew
up things were different you know there
was a focus on family and community and
church and i think that you know we knew
each other and and i'm not saying that
the people in uvalde don't know each
other but i think that that that's been
that's been robbed from us our culture
has changed over the last you know 30 or
40 years and and in in the there's been
an attack on those on those things in
particular and i just think that kids
are exposed to all kinds of horrible
stuff nowadays too i look back and i
think about the you know the horrible
stuff that they hear when they listen to
rap music the video games that they
watch from a really early age with all
of this horrible violence and stuff and
i just think that
you know in rap music and violent video
games now is the united states the only
country with rap music no
is the united states the only country
where kids play violent video games no
are we the only country with this many
guns per capita yes we are
uh tucker carlson talked about the
lockdowns the lockdowns cause mental
illness and mental illness leads to
shootings and you be uh you do the math
oh so the lockdowns dramatically
increase the incidence of mental illness
among young people and in 10 days we've
seen two mass shootings by mentally ill
young people could there be a connection
now that's not finger pointing it's not
to blame fouchy for yesterday's shooting
we're not that low we're not joe biden
but if people are becoming mentally ill
because they're disconnected from others
what can we do to connect them to others
and thereby reduce the incidence of
mental illness that's a so of course
this is a very very
um
pathetic misunderstanding of what it
means to say mental illness but we're
not the only country that dealt with
covet in fact many other countries did
weigh more in terms of restrictions why
aren't they having more shootings and by
the way texas did almost nothing which
is where the uvalde shooting took place
and were the only ones with the mass
shooting problems and by the way the
mass shootings didn't start during or
after covid they've been going on for a
very long time so they will not stop
they will blame anything but guns
and now i want to talk about the mental
health component i'm going to play a
clip for you now
of republican congressman tony gonzalez
who represents uvalde texas
he said the issue here is mental health
now we're going to play the clip
and then i'm going to specifically tell
you why it's pathetic for tony gonzalez
to be talking about this take a look
to the root of the root of a lot of
these issues is mental health and you
know this has been evident for for a
long time in this country there is an
evil that is growing that is rising that
we have to we have to curb and and part
of that is mental health covid certainly
didn't help okay
the root of the issue is mental health
and covid didn't help
the um
america doesn't have a particularly
worse mental health crisis than the rest
of the free world we have a gun culture
problem where people see guns as a
solution to problems that's a real
problem we have super easy access to
guns in many states and not enough
access to mental health treatment
but i looked into tony gonzalez tony
gonzalez has regularly voted against
improving health care which would
include access to mental health tony
gonzalez voted no on the women's health
protection act of 2021. in june of 2020
tony gonzalez voted against expanding
the affordable care act oh it's mental
illness but he voted against increasing
access to mental health treatment in
december of 2019 tony gonzalez voted
against allowing the federal government
to negotiate lower prescription drug
prices in may of 2019 tony gonzalez
voted against lowering prescription
prescription drug costs i could go on
and by the way
in february of 2019 tony gonzalez voted
against giving law enforcement agencies
more time
to do background checks for gun sales
and he voted against requiring
background checks for all firearms sales
and this is why i said yesterday when a
republican or anyone says this is about
mental illness
ask what legislation they supported or
opposed when it comes to access to
health care because this guy is now
saying the problem is everything but
guns
but he voted against expanding access to
health care
multiple times he voted again simply
give law enforcement more time to do the
background checks when they are actually
uh indicated in certain states
no
this guy wants to point to anything
that's not guns even if his own voting
record tells us he doesn't actually take
those things seriously
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a teacher who called
a teacher about the idea of arming
teachers in school
hey david tim here teacher from
pennsylvania look there is no political
will to act on gun legislation so
instead i suggest we just start treating
schools like an airport there you go
dogs high security teams with swat gear
and long guns
guys on the roof treat it like an
airport they come in they put their
backpack through a scanner there's metal
doors there's security teams the whole
thing there is no political will to act
on gun legislation let's just treat
schools like a prison and just own that
this is the society that we live in a
disgusting depraved society keep up the
great work work david talk to you soon
now the circumstances here in the united
states are so sick
that i can't tell whether this teacher
is saying this tongue-in-cheek like
saying hey listen if we can't deal with
guns i guess we just turn the schools
into prison-like circumstances and and i
don't know if he's saying it as in like
obviously that's not a good idea
or if he's genuinely saying
we've got to do that he i i
the circumstances are so depraved that i
don't know if he's being sarcastic or if
he's just giving up and saying we have
no other choice that's exactly what we
have to do
um
wow what a situation
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to continue talking about a
number of different things uh we're
going to talk about a juneteenth
controversy we're going to talk about
um a settlement involving twitter and
user data on the bonus show it's been a
big shooting heavy show so we're going
to take a break from the shooting stuff
on the bonus show but unfortunately i
have way more to talk about tomorrow
including the forthcoming nra convention
so you can sign up for the bonus show at
joinpackman.com
and then otherwise we'll be back
tomorrow and then we've got multiple
streams coming up into the weekend the
nra convention the trump rally in
wyoming which i'm sure will be
completely unhinged so much content over
the next few days
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below